et la tribu vivant
choquants et honteux ils sont suivis par
un public est très jeune c'est les
incite à faire ça et en fait le problème
c'est qu'il ya aucune certitude sur
l'efficacité et il ya même des médecins
qui disent que ça pourrait être
cancérigène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les menaces
sur ophélie meunier ça c'est
inadmissible bien entendu vraiment c'est
incroyable de vivre ça aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aussi on peut pas on peut
pas vivre ça gilles verdez bien sûr les
laits les menaces sont effroyables
heureusement qu'elle a été protégé il
faut que ça cesse et elle a tout notre
soutien et après je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous le problème c'est que
à force de stigmatiser les musulmans je
parle pas de l'émission ingénierie en
particulier mais en général si voilà tu
fais un petit pas une autre et c'est
sale c'est vrai que l'on va on va les
forcer au repli et chaude à leurs forces
et au communautarisme on va les forcer à
vivre entre eux et on va voir ce qu'on
ne veut pas voir c'est à dire des
endroits ils vont être entre eux il faut
les intégrer la religion musulmane
célèbre légende l'intime que chacun a
envie d'exprimer les
intégrer je vais pas dire il faut les
intégrer ils sont tous intégrés je suis
désolé il est géré et mongi zidi et
aujourd'hui ils disent on est on fait
tout bien et on est on est mis de côté
où on est on est stigmatisée aujourd'hui
les journalistes ils sont menacés dans
les dictatures dans les pays
autoritaires et donc ça n'est pas normal
qu'en france des journalistes soient
menacés ça c'est le premier point et
ensuite parler de l'islam radical est ce
que c'est dangereux aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est un sujet qui peut être
compliqué les polémiques elle fait aussi
appeler les autres polémiquer sur ce
reportage à savoir qu'ils étaient à
charge et que voilà il y avait des
méthodes tc pas très journalistique pour
pour sa fabrication mais c'est pas une
raison non évidemment les faux-pas
jamais justifier les menaces voilà mais
je trouve qu'à une récupération
politique qui peut prêter à des clichés
des amalgames qui sont pas très joyeux
voilà je suis je vais je vais proposer
un documentaire assez vite chez pacy -
kung fu ni moi aussi je vais essayer de
faire un reportage aussi je vous dis sur
beaucoup de musulmans qui ont marre
aussi naître c'est la stigmatiser voilà
et qu'ils aient travaillé normalement
qui font tous bien et qui se retrouve un
petit peu mythe monnaie ça aussi
j'essayais de faire un dock nature dans
les zones et c'est le cas dans la
balance son pote sur un autre angle
parce que c'est vrai que ça on n'en voit
jamais des dom tom alors je m'en veux
aussi parce qu'on l'a jamais proposé à
la chaîne j'ai eu une idée tout à
l'heure en envoyant tout ce qui se
passait et on va le faire on fera un btp
spécial que j'animerai là dessus je vous
dis parce que c'est vrai que c'est
important aussi de voilà parce que
aujourd'hui ça c'est inadmissible ce qui
arrive à ophélie et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je vous dis des musulmans
ils sont de plus en plus de mal
à vivre en france normalement oui pense
qu'il faut quand même mesurer la
violence et la portée médiatique de ce
genre de documentaire qui sont
clairement à charge envers des millions
de personnes qui se sentent visés et
donc ce genre de documentaire va
contribuer encore à leur isolement voilà
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure si
je vous dit rien il ya la direction de
m6 teint qui m'écrit en direct elles
sont interdites de stigmatiser
aucunement les musulmans mais uniquement
l'islam radical les principaux témoins
qui s'exprimait sur le sujet étaient eux
mêmes musulmans ils sont aussi menacés
aujourd'hui vous n'en tenez voilà ce que
nous venons d important merci m6 est en
tout cas de répondre oui la différence
quand le bas peuple légende m6 ils
t'appellent ai dit oui c'était sur
l'islam radical la différence c'est que
les gens ne font pas la différence entre
l'islam radical et l'islam il ya quatre
millions de musulmans en france plus de
4 millions il y en a 90 milles qui sont
radio isa midi peut-être radicaliser et
4000 qui sont vraiment dur dur vous
croyez vraiment que les 4 millions ils
foutent le bordel partout en france
comme c'est dit dans le reportage moi je
pense pas il ya eu les pères des
musulmans qui sont venus ici aussi moi
mon père il est venu en france pour
travailler pas venu [ __ ] le bordel moi
je suis pas venu pour suivre le bordel
il ya plein de gens qui vont travailler
le matin qui rentrent le qui partent le
matin qui rentrent le soir uniquement
pour être bien pour vivre en paix pour
vivre leur religion en paix et à mettre
des reportages comme ça ça comme a dit
gilles tout à l'heure et comme j'avais
dit l'autre fois ça à faire qu'ils vont
rester entre de plus en plus et ils vont
croire que ils sont détestés par tout le
monde c'est ça qu'on est en train de
bien après quand même après la menace de
manoeuvre
énorme et qui condamne mais elles
viennent de ti les menaces de mort elles
viennent pas d'un mec qui va travailler
tous les matins qui fait sa religion
calmement elles viennent justement de
quelqu'un qui est pas content parce
qu'on n'a pas les listes à 10 ans
radicale mais si moi j'ai mes potes qui
m'ont dit même pas team 19 ans nous ce
qu'on veut c'est être empreint en paix
non nos parents les a traités de
[ __ ] on les a traités decrouille
ils ont baissé la tête nous on veut pas
baisser la tête on juste vivent
normalement c'est tout c'est pas
compliqué à comprendre
j'aime bien ça très sympathique et voilà
c'est une nouvelle technique qui vient
de colombie elle consiste à envelopper
les parties du corps il ya du gras en
grande partie comme par exemple se vante
les bras les jambes mais c'est plutôt
galère ça permettrait d'atténuer la
cellulite les vergetures et de modeler
le corps en déplaçant les graisses alors
tout le monde en parle de cette
technique qui fait peur la liaison
thérapie regarde
c'est que je rigole que j'ai 10
[Musique]
il faut placer du vent
mais c'est incroyable c'est à dire
qu'elle le garde 48 heures ça c'est
incroyable si si elle a cessé ses trucs
et après c'est vrai que c'est comme
quand vous vous casser le bras mon truc
comme ça veut forcément
fin et le média tranché c'est juste le
muscle qui font ces incroyables est ce
que vous trouvez que cette technique est
irresponsable qui se regarde oui assez
choquants et honteux ils sont suivis par
un public est très jeune ça les incite à
faire ça moi c'est quand ça m'énervait
que les influenceurs c'est qu'ils nous
expliquent qu'on absout sans rien faire
on devient riche sans rien faire on
maigrit sans rien faire il faut mettre
en avant l'effort mais c'est vrai nom
mais après après si c'est leur truc
après moi je vois là je je sais que ça
c'est dangereux mais je pense pas
qu'elle se rende compte de ça bien sûr
qu'ils vendent des bureaux de lui c'est
pas grave ça touche à la santé comme ya
des dangers c'est dangereux ils sont
responsables aux enseignes une
responsabilité qu'il est en fait le
problème c'est qu'il ya aucune certitude
sur l'efficacité et il ya même des
médecins qui disent que ça pourrait être
cancérigène
je n'aime pas ce côté péjoratif mais là
c'est un bon la vie m'a dit c'est non
oui mais alors influent sur c'est un
métier aujourd'hui je suis à la visite
et responsable que là on l' occurrence
franchement à part tout moment où où ça
touche le corps le corps la
restructuration la santé le paramédical
ça devrait être totalement encadré c'est
à dire qu'on aurait on devrait pas avoir
le droit d'être sur instagram snap
château autres sur des sujets qui sont
telles que le médical le paramédical la
santé ça devrait être totalement
interdits et bien il devrait y avoir une
législation là dessus après on fait ce
qu'on veut si on veut vendre un un pull
un je ne sais pas quoi mais en revanche
sur le médical et le paramédical devrait
totalement encadrer ce qu'a fait là
quand elle dit
pas contre ce qu'elle fait mais si elles
seront bien sûr la puissance des réseaux
socialement jusqu'à l'été venu justement
ici pour une histoire qu'il avait foutu
dans la merde avec les réseaux sociaux
la mer la puissance qu'elle a elle sait
très bien qu'elle peut parler à des
jeunes pourquoi il a dit gilles boulet
dont le prix de la 10 mois jean pad il
pris pour 90 euros franchement les gens
et loyal et ils vont dire j'y vais c'est
vrai vous
sur cette génération passée jeunes mais
cette génération c'est je pense qu'elle
fait même pas ça pour l'argent pour
c'est que toutes ces générations
maintenant quand tu viens un peu avec
eux toute la journée c'est coucou je
suis en train de manger coucou je vais
l'acheter enough
shaima vous aviez il avait une chanson
préférée qu'au bout du chantier
maintenant c'est la chanson sur laquelle
grichka est parti on était on était
trois autour de lui avec véronique qu'on
embrasse très fort ce soir sa soeur la
soeur des jumeaux véronique chaïma et
moi et il est parti sur ces belles notes
et son label mélodieuse de shy'm à des
amateurs de cèpes sauf à l'eau et
non à l'austérité
[Musique]
aux a et b
n y est
et ça ne l'est ah
non en famille neo soupire d'aisé
shadding innover mais aux yeux des comme
ça des
[Musique]
white chez
asuka
talent chez grasset
[Musique]
à
foyers cet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
endroit est tombée ce jeudi en début
d'après midi elle a décidé de révoquer
le placement sous placerait électronique
des époux balkany la justice renvoie
donc en prison patrick balkany en sera
maire de levallois perret c'est une
ville dans le 92 et son épouse alors que
la saute ans venait juste de tomber
isabelle balkany a avalé une boîte de
médicaments a été directement
hospitalisé à la laisser un message ou
voix vous dévoiler dans un instant lors
alice pourquoi les balkany sont-ils
renvoyer en prison enfin envoyé pour
l'une et renvoyer peau et bien parce que
la cour d'appel a décidé de la
révocation du placement en souffrance et
électroniques il faut savoir que
lorsqu'on est condamné on peut obtenir
une espèce de faveur de la part de la
justice
permet d'être placé sous bracelet
électronique et qui permet d'effectuer
une peine chez soi avec un dispositif
électronique avec des heures de sortie
avec un
lieu de sortie etc et
il se trouve que les balkany n'ont pas
respecté ses obligations là et quand
donc par conséquent le ministère public
a demandé la révocation le message
inquiétant d'isabelle balkany sur les
réseaux cet après midi isabelle a posté
un message très important sur la photo
on peut lire il est temps que ça y est
temps que ça s'arrête jamais juste
dormir dormir épuisée par l'âge le mien
la haine des autres l'angoissent pour
l'homme de ma vie la blessure
inguérissable du gommage de ce que j'ai
pu faire de positif trois petits points
merci à ceux qui m'ont fait le bonheur
de mai mais bien mes amours à quatre
pattes et il est temps que ça s'arrête
avec ce message gilles verdez c'est très
inquiétant parce que l avait déjà fait
une tentative de suicide donc là patrick
balkany a appelé le samu immédiatement
qui est intervenue elle a été
hospitalisée
c'est vrai qu'on a peur pour elle c'est
vrai que ça a sonné sans foi mais eux
disent pourquoi votre bracelet sonne
parce que quand on va chercher le
courrier la propriété est grande quand
on va au portail quand on va à l'annexé
voir nos petits-enfants ça sonne mais la
justice répond arrêtez de vous moquer de
nous on vous a vu à levallois vous dites
que vous avez été pris dans des
embouteillages et que vous pouviez pas
être de retour à la bonne heure c'est
faux et donc les juges en ont eu marre
thierry khayat vous habitez levallois
oui tout à fait ça vous révolte cette
décision oui parce que si vous voulez
moi je connais les balkany je les vois
je les ai vus pendant longtemps et c'est
des personnes qui sont bon d'abord très
âgées je pense que ils ont été en haut
de la fiche ils ont été pour moi ils ont
été humiliés ils ont été ils ont été
punis je suis havrais levalloisien je
sais qu'ils sont très proches de leurs
administrés et j'ai été outré de la
manière dont six sont traités qui sont
des justiciables comme tout le monde
voilà il y avait il des faits un
bracelet électronique il devait voilà
avoir des obligations il ya eu 100 ans
en stand by le déni de justice qui a
depuis le début aura non se considère
comme d'ajouter ma part
connaissons pas casser tout le monde ne
vont pas en prison messieurs c'est
génial et deux essais pendant
si longtemps elle a déjà ordonné cet
été
à londres et ceux qui sont comme tout le
monde ne sont pas traités comme
justement comme il le faut on cherche
des gens comme tout le monde mais en
fait c'est pas parce qu'ils ont été élus
ils ont été des mères enfin mr
extraordinaire de levallois que pour
autant ils ont été condamnés pour fraude
fiscale et prise illégale d'intérêt ça
existe ça oui isaiah un ami comme tout
le monde ils n'auraient pas été en
prison il faut le faire parce
qu'aujourd'hui les gens comme tout le
monde c'est le double pour les gens
parce qu'ils le savent la question
monsieur sait qu'un voyou d'inaugurer un
brass électronique est ce qu'on lui
laisserait sans chance de faire
n'importe connaissait avant de sonner
vous croyez que monsieur balkany intime
aux yeux dans la rue ce banquier
matthieu vos partys balkany est assez
bête jeu pour faire j'adore elle tarde à
gérer il te dit monsieur mathieu c'est
la première fois que pas bêtes ils
sortent de prison parce qu il enrhumé et
il va danser dans la rue de la loire il
va danser le lendemain qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous dites aux gens
erraient faut être bête à 100 fois
maintenant ses parts à torcy
le 28 décembre 2021 et le 3 janvier 2022
grichka puis igor bogdanoff nous
quittait à six jours d'intervalle depuis
les deux frères inséparables ont laissé
un grand vide dans le coeur des français
j'ai beaucoup de peine ce soir chaïma
qui a partagé d'amis de grichka jusqu'à
la fin sort pour la première fois du
silence dans tpm paie
des charges chaïma merci d'être là vous
êtes vous étiez la compagne de grichka
vous avez perdu votre compagnon donc
sans descendre quand la france entière a
perdu deux personnes on aimait vraiment
énormément qui nous montrent déjà vous
dire il me manque beaucoup vous avez
rencontré quand christian comme vous
l'avez rencontrée ça fait trois ans
trois ans après oui
nous étions amis sur facebook d'accord
après il m'a proposé de venir de faire
un stage si en france et c'était comme
ça l'occasion et vous venez vous venez
d'où en fait je suis marocaine d'accord
la môme on embrasse tous les marocains
ne regarde voilà qu'on aime en décembre
dernier donc les deux frères ont
contracté le qu'ovide il vous parlait
parfois du virus d'un bien ou chaïma oui
oui nous en parler évidemment il n'était
pas déjà n'était pas anti vaccins oui
j'ai déjà entendu par yale affolera des
gens qu'ils étaient en direct c'est pas
du tout cas moi ils m'ont encouragé m
vacciner 1 vacciner mes parents donc y
avait pas de difficultés là dessus c'est
plutôt attention aux gestes barrières
ils portaient le masque ça fait des mois
et des mois qu'on ne faisait plus la
bise donc il était conscient de ce qui
se passait sauf qu'ils ne se sentaient
pas concernés ils pensaient qu'ils
étaient suffisamment fort suffisamment
robuste pour ne pas être attaqué par ce
virus mais il était totalement conscient
de ce qui se passait dans ce monde et je
voudrais juste te remercier cyril parce
que tu as été extrêmement bienveillant
valérie également un fait une très belle
émission qu'un hasard on les adorait
shocker break en partie de la famille au
niveau 8 16 parler une fois à l'hôpital
ou pas du tout une permanence permanent
fermé non seulement ils étaient à deux
trois chambres d'écart ils avaient leurs
téléphones portables ils se sont mis
dans un bon coeur c'est-à-dire qui ne
répondra plus personne c'est pour ça
qu'on devait y aller sinon on n'avait
aucune nouvelle et il s'appelait d'une
chambre à l'autre pour savoir s'il avait
mangé quel était le taux de saturation
qu'avaient dit les médecins jusqu'au
bout en fait l'un s'est soucié de
l'autre plus que de lui-même à chaque
fois ça a toujours été ça alors
malheureusement le 28 décembre griche
qu'est ce qu'elle va nous quitter des
suites de la maladie
on sait qu'ils gore il n'a pas su dire
qu'à était parti non du tout du tout
parce qu'ils étaient il était dans le
temps il était lui aussi un tube est
donc dans le coma il ne l'a pas su donc
fort
c'est un sentiment
parce que là je me sens tout seul et à
chaque fois je pense à lui à chaque fois
quand quelqu'un parle de grichka
toujours j'ai les larmes aux yeux parce
qu'il l'a il a hélas il a laissé un vide
que personne ne peut le remplir et
parce qu'il a fait beaucoup de choses
pour moi il était toujours à côté des
mots de moi et c'est un sentiment
horrible est tellement difficile de
de ne plus voir la personne que tu aimes
que que tu avais que d'été de très bons
moments ensemble
réseaux sociaux et même site
pornographique nordahl le landais ce
permis tout il aurait même flirté avec
miss aisne alors qu'il était en prison
on va en parler dans un instant alors
est-ce que cela vous choque
les la détention et les conditions de
détention de d'ornano landais font
scandale justement la malle merci encore
bêtes là vous étiez donc incarcéré à
fresnes et vous avez posté mais aussi de
nombreuses vidéos sur les réseaux
sociaux alors que les portables sont
interdits en prison dont on se dit
comment comment ça se passe bah en fait
c'est simple un mois j'ai commencé par
faire des vidéos snap pourquoi vous
étiez aux 120 discrétion pour trafic de
stupéfiants d'accord ouais et et en vrai
j'ai commencé par faire des vidéos des
vidéos cela pour montrer en fait mon
quotidien l'accord mets de base c'était
plus pour en fait c'était pour moi
c'était comme un nouveau jeu vidéo en
fait je venais de découvrir ce laps est
en fait j'y ai pris goût mais les gens
ce qui se dit normal c'est comment on
peut se procurer un téléphone en prison
voilà ce que c'est exactement dans ne va
pas c'est un secret de polichinelle tout
dans la la c'est vrai comme j'ai dit oui
fm tv 99 % des détenus a bien sûr des
téléphones pas vraiment prison va pas se
mentir effectivement on a une
administration pénitentiaire qui au
regard de la politique carcérale qui est
menée d orientation qui peuvent être
prises effectivement on peut laisser
penser qu'on achète la paix sociale
c'est pas faux du tout alors aujourd'hui
où lé parloir fait les parloirs servent
en fait des lieux d'entrée pour les
téléphones monsieur on a aussi un fléau
qui est en fait les projections parce
qu'aujourd'hui sur les domaines
pénitentiaire vous entré comme dans un
moulin et vous balancer au dessus des
murs que vous êtes donc grosso modo les
téléphones aujourd'hui vous allez faire
un tour à fleury mérogis aux services de
sécurité vous avez des armes et
l'arrière les murs de la prison de
joux l'on remplit en fait qu'ils ont
neuf sous blister je peux on peut penser
par exemple aux parents de saiss c'est
exactement c'est aux parents de du cas
il faut y penser bah oui parce que c'est
juste insupportable
à gerber alors je sais pas si c'est des
trous dans la raquette où je sais pas si
c'est de la corruption ou je sais pas si
c'est parce que le travail est mal fait
mais il ya un vrai problème comment ça
c'est qu'ils reçoivent à une femme dans
l'andante dans le parloir et cette somme
donc apporte des choses donc a pas de
fouilles en fait systématique quand
quelqu'un est à l'isoloir par le 'pce'
dangereux connor va le landais ya pas d
flore stéphanie qui les choses même
quand vous
qu'en parlant alors là mais c'est un jeu
je suis content que vous abordez le
sujet pascal en fait aujourd'hui c'est
pas que le professionnalisme des
personnels qui à remettre en question
aujourd'hui ces législateurs qui va
remettre ses frappes so lu ment avec ce
qu'il a raison qu'on a aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui dise enfin parloir et bien
pour le sait une simple fouille par
palpation à la famille et pas quelqu'un
par palpation oui effectivement vous
avez
99% probabilité de rien de prouvé leur
pratique est aujourd'hui une fouille
intégrale d'une personne détenue à la
sortie d'un parloir il faut qu'on puisse
pouvoir prouver que effectivement qu'on
suspecte qui l'a fait rentrer quelque
chose et derrière il ya un formulaire de
50 pages à remplir mais une fois que le
téléphone est dans la cellule n'y a pas
trente six mille cachette donc pourquoi
tous les jours y après une fouille pour
des pour un organe le landais oui c'est
vrai pas d'accord avec la malle pas
obligé mais les jours la même cellule
parce que derrière si on fouille tu n'as
pas le droit la même cellule ça va se
terminer par une version mango de plein
de choses excessives à considérer que
c'est n'importe quoi
alors qu'il
ne savait pas wilfrid ce que vous venez
de dire je suis sûr que les gens qui
nous écoutent ça ne savais pas ça ça
aurait dû faire une marche sur la tête
lordat le landais qui est un prédateur
il est dans sa cellule on n'a pas le
droit d'aller le droit de fouiller
toujours parce que sinon on va se
prendre un truc juridique
aujourd'hui si vous voulez inopinée de
la cellule de le landais il faut
derrière c'est un peu comme ce que
j'expliquais pour la fouille intégrale à
la sortie du parlant il faut qu'on
puisse avoir des éléments factuels sur
lesquels se basent
justifier qu'on est en train d'aller fou
de brigade et même un ex détenu
qui pète un câble et moi je prends
souvent cet exemple ans et que
c'est pas parce qu'il a fait ça à
quelqu'un qui nous que je ne connais pas
que ça va me toucher au sommet ça nous a
tous touchés face aux actes eux mans
donc maylis elle nous a comme souci pour
vraiment répondre à ta question si
demain il était en prison avec pas que
moi mais des gens qui réfléchissent à
peu près comme moi ça serait un massacre
pour lui ah ouais ouais vraiment cessé
c'est vrai vous en avez conscience aux
gens de deux profils en tout cas où
effectivement les affaires sont
particulièrement médiatisé il est bien
évident que la migration pénitentiaire
n'a pas d'autre choix que de prendre des
mesures entre guillemets de
protection
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]